If the only place left you call home
has been invaded by horrifying titans,
what would you do?
These terrifying creatures
are invading your city, killing your friends.
And family, and it's up to you to stop them.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do, and how to beat
the horrifying Titans in attack on Titan.
Season two These kids have no idea that
some of them are about to be ripped apart
by flesh eating titans.
This young group of scouts
sit and waste their days away
within the walls of this garrison,
and they all wonder
what the hell they are doing here.
The fight is out there, not here.
And one of them even thinks
about sneaking away to go check on his family
that lives in a nearby village.
But that's when they get word
that Titans have breached the wall yet again.
And this head scout leader
tells these rookies to go alert
all of the nearby towns,
telling them to evacuate now.
And these guys prepare to die for their home
all over again.
But this guy's mustache
means that he's in charge
and he leads everybody away from the Titans,
telling them to avoid all combat and escape
as he dives head
first into battle to give them more time.
OK, this is absolutely horrifying.
These scouts were ill prepared
and stood no chance
to stop the horde of flesh eating monsters.
They literally had no choice
but to avoid the fight.
Option one, using their horses,
which are bred to be faster than a titan.
They run and hide within the nearby trees,
but only hiding in the trees
that are taller and bigger than the Titans
chasing them. Or Option two.
They ignore orders and stay to help Mustached
Warrior and hide within the building itself
and then flee in the early morning hours
when most of the titans around
would be more dormant
and would have given the group
an easier time in getting away,
assuming they survived the night.
Both options are risky,
however, as the guardians of the land
within these walls, their duty demands
that they must warn
the citizens of a Titan invasion.
But if this was the case,
they should have planned it better
and should have implemented
some sort of primitive alarm system.
They could have warned
the public of the invasion more quickly
and effectively than simply sending messages
to each individual town,
because this is not only slow
and ineffective,
but as you saw,
that means no scouts were able
to stay behind to help a mustache warrior
because they all had to spread the word.
Obviously, they don't have cell phones
or two way radio technology to warn everyone.
And this problem
shouldn't be too huge of an issue to solve
because primitive alarm systems
have been in use for a millennial
and have taken various forms
throughout history
from the use of animals such as dogs, geese
and livestock placed around areas to vocalize
when trouble was nearby
to even alarm bells being signaled by scouts
placed within towers.
And this is one example of an alarm system
that this city could have built.
Bells by design are loud as hell, and one
example of how loud they can be can be found
in the East End District of London,
a church known as Old Church.
These bells can be heard
when rung throughout the entire
borough of Hackney, London, which is over
4.5 miles away from where Bo Church is.
If sound can roughly travel one mile
every 5 seconds
now taking into account
temperature and humidity,
this means that the sounds coming from a bell
will be able to reach
4.5 miles away in about 4.5 seconds
or 20 miles in 22.5 seconds.
Even the fittest trained endurance horses
at most can travel 20 miles in one
and a half hours.
Now, I'm not saying that normally alarm bells
can be heard 20 miles away,
but you get my point.
Using horses as a means of an alert
system was inefficient to begin with
because these guys can only alert
everyone in the far away towns
as fast as their horses can take them, which
isn't nearly as fast as the speed of sound.
Obviously,
the citizens of this place should have built
scout towers around the perimeter
of all the walls as well.
As all over the land, with an average gap
between towers of about four miles, making
sure that each tower
would ring at the first sound, heard
from the bells
being rung closest to the wall,
which would then create
a sort of domino effect
where the bells sound
would travel all the way to the towns
intended in a much shorter time frame.
This means that at the very first sighting
of a Titan citizens in town
two miles away could have been informed
of this within minutes of the tines
being spotted.
Another method could have been how Pippin led
the signal beacon to call on Rowan
for help
in The Lord of the Rings Return of the King
by using signal beacons to alert each tower
one by one to inform the intended
town of any incoming threats
because they didn't have any pre-installed
alarm system of any sort.
Considering how big of a problem tie
and czar was a huge mistake to begin with.
This mustached warrior is the second top dog
in the unit, second only to Captain
Levi in skill and kills off Titan after Titan
until only four remain.
Suddenly
he comes across the most horrifying thing
ever this beast Titan and it can't speak.
And this monster steals
his gear and leaves him to beg for his life
as the rest of the hungry Titans
eat him alive elsewhere.
Back at the main city,
they've just gone through hell
trying to save themselves from this female
titan, taking her away to experiment on her.
But they don't realize that this is only the
beginning of more terrifying things to come.
And this group suddenly spots a tion
within the walls of their decimated city.
And this priest orders them
to keep their mouths shut
and to keep that titan out of sunlight.
Horrifying.
Everybody here to the bone.
Up until now, almost no one knew what these
darn near indestructible walls were made of.
And the glasses girl interrogates
the shit out of this priest.
But he says nothing.
Even with a threat of her
dropping him from the top of the wall.
And this makes her think that all of these
walls are made out of tight in flesh.
Elsewhere, half human, half titan hybrid
Eren sits resting along with his longtime
friend Mikasa, as they try and recover
from the female Titan's wrath
that recently wreaked havoc on the city.
But suddenly they get word
along with everybody else
that titans have breached the walls
and nearby.
These guys then head off to fight the Titans
coming from the breach within wall rows.
But on the way, glasses girl thinks that
because Eren is half human, half Titan,
they make a plan for
Eren to use his Titan body to somehow
fill the hole from within the gate.
But there's no guarantee that
he'll be able to do it. But he has no choice.
If they don't close the wall soon, thousands
more titans will come through
and everybody will die.
Meanwhile,
the survivors of mustached warriors
group reached their hometown to warn
everybody of the incoming titans.
But something is not right as this kid sees
his village already destroyed
but with no bodies in sight.
No bodies except for this one fallen titan.
And it directly speaks to him saying,
welcome home.
Freaking this kid out
who is caught right before
this officer tells them to keep on moving
in the middle of the night in total darkness,
this group of scouts rides
close along the wall rows
to find exactly where the breach is.
But they eventually run into this other group
of scouts, meaning they've come full circle
and no one has found the breach
within the wall.
And no one knows how the Titans got in
freaking everyone out and they decide to rest
for the night
in an abandoned military post nearby.
Back with Eren and his crew.
They prepare to ride out into thin territory
to stop the incoming Titans.
But Glasses girl again tries
to find out what this priest knows
about the Titan within the wall.
And he finally tells her
that a girl within the Scout Regiment named
Christa is the key to the tie in wall secret
and that they need to find her
as soon as possible.
Eren then realizes that her group
is already out on the front lines
where the Titans are,
which means they need to find her now.
But it's too late
because that's when the group of scouts back
at the abandoned military outpost realized
they've just been found by titans.
The veterans within the group
tell the rookies to hide
within the castle tower
and they jump off of the top of the tower
to fight these flesh eating beasts head on.
OK, this is freaking nuts.
And because of these scouts stupidity,
we are now screwed
It was clear
that while checking the wall earlier,
the moon was being covered by the clouds,
which caused everything around them
to be almost pitch black with the moon
coming and going throughout the night.
This is what allowed the Titans
to surprise these scouts
right outside their tower in the first place,
because with the moon being covered out
there, these scouts couldn't see shit.
But then this makes them look so stupid
because if you look at where they are
located, what is the one thing
that basically advertised their location
at that castle tower for the Titans to see?
It was their lit fire.
The only light source at the top of that
tower with a 360 degree view of everything.
And unless something or someone
got real close, the scouts sitting next
to the fire couldn't see anything anyways.
They were begging to have a problem
and all the Titans
anywhere
nearby could come and see their stupid flame
because the deeper the darkness, the brighter
the light.
Now, it's not clear up to this point.
How good the eyesight of titans are.
However, a healthy human
eye on average will be able to see a lit
candle flame as far as 1.6 miles away.
If there aren't any obstructions in the way
and these idiots
felt the need to light up their location
at the tower just like a lighthouse.
Their mission
was to find the breach in the wall.
They had to wait until early morning anyways
before they could move on.
They had no reason to blast out
their location as much as they did.
They should have had a group
keep watch at the top of the tower,
and if they're worried about getting caught,
then they can just bundle up, deal with it,
and have two man shifts
rotating out every 20 to 30 minutes
at a time.
Also,
from the moment that they left the garrison,
the rookies should have been given back
their ODM gear.
This would have doubled their attack power
and increases their chances of survival
because now the Titans are here and only
the scout veterans have their ODM gear.
Killing off a handful of Titans
will be more than possible for them,
but it will not do much
to stop the overall horde coming this way.
And the fact that we're in well-known
Titan territory means that killing
all of these monsters is likely going
to bring even more attention to ourselves.
And we also just noticed that random
Titan passes by.
It's something we've never seen before,
which means we shouldn't
bring more attention to ourselves
at this point
because we don't know what we're dealing with
and the capabilities of that giant titan
making him a wild card.
This is one instance where the veterans need
to sacrifice themselves
and draw the titans away from the tower and
into the forest, leaving the rookies inside.
Now this place looks like
it is made out of stone
and will usually be built directly on rock
or have substantial foundations
built underneath the castle.
To support the overall structure
of the foundation.
The inclusion
of having substantial foundations
to support the overall structure
usually means that there's a decent chance
very large basement underneath it,
and coupled
with the fact
that this place was built on flat land
increases the odds that there is a basement
of some sort
that the rookies can use to hide it.
Because retreating to enclosed spaces away
from the Titans line of sight will be one way
that they can survive,
at least for a little while.
So I would order a portion
of the Scout rookies
to make this their top priority
in finding out if there is a basement
once the basement is found,
I am ordering all of the rookies
to head down into the basement
and armed themselves as best as they can.
This will allow them
to concentrate their attack onto one spot
and not get surrounded by titans
because they'll have to go through
one entrance way
in order to get to them at best.
This will allow us to take out
most of the horde while minimizing attention
being brought to ourselves,
since will be leading the Titans
deeper underground to get to us.
Outside, the veterans kill every single titan
bastard that comes their way.
Slicing and dicing bloody body parts
beautifully but back inside,
Titans have broken into the tower,
climbing up the stairs
to the terrified rookies.
This study Riner tries to block the door,
struggling and wrestling
with this cannibal demon
just before his bud. Bertolt
and the rest of the rookies help him out
by crashing a literal cannon into it.
But just then, another titan
sneaks up and tries to eat this kid.
But Reiner protects him, letting a tear
into his arm while carrying it up the stairs.
He is going to jump out of the window,
taking the Titan down along with him.
But just at the last moment,
the rest of the rookies
manage to kick it off of him,
having it fall to its death.
Christa then tends to Reiner wounds
and her kind of actions turn him on a little
too much.
They realize that the scouts fighting outside
won't be able to hold out much longer.
Suddenly, a massive rock comes hurtling
through the sky and crashes into their horses
while a second one comes flying
in and crashes into the top of the tower,
killing the other two veterans.
And they all see dozens more titans incoming.
And they all start to think
that these Titan tactics are way too good
and they suspect that this beast titan
that they just saw earlier outside is somehow
ordering this attack from a distance.
Meanwhile,
the last of the scouts die a gruesome death
as more titan surround the castle tower
ready to peel the flesh off of these guys.
This is Bones.
Justin, this girl Yama borrows a knife
and jumps off of the top of the tower,
plunging herself down into a sea of monsters
as she injures
her hand and turns into a titan.
This shocks everyone,
including Reiner and Bertolt,
who realize that this Titan is the same one
who ate their friend out in the wild
two years ago, meaning that Jamie
is a murderer and the group starts to wonder
whether she's a friend or a foe. OK.
This is a wiggly, declared type shit
and now our closest
ally is another one of those monster
cannibal freaks.
Now, these kiddos up
until now have seen humor for a while,
and from the looks of things,
it seems like she is trustworthy.
But that's exactly what we thought
of the female Titan earlier,
and she was batshit insane,
which means we can't trust
all of her actions.
However,
the one thing that will be harder to hide
will be a mere subconscious tendencies
that she's displayed so far.
And a by observing
these will be better able to understand
the Ymir's overall character and mindset.
But to do
this will have to observe the little things
because while the tongue may lie,
the nuances and subtleties in someone's
character is often far harder to mask.
And it's these subtle examples
that will provide some direct insight
into someone's character.
Telltale signs can easily be
found in how someone takes food at a buffet
or a military canteen.
Do they always take a lot of food?
Do they take the last bit of food?
Not caring
if there will be enough for the next person?
Or do they tend to have one sided
conversations, lack
perspective, don't reciprocate effort,
or frequently demean and intimidate
and bully others.
These are the subtle signs of someone
that is self-centered.
And if we stop and think,
we'll be able to remember that.
From what we've seen of Ymir
thus far, it's clear
that she naturally is selfish,
cynical, uncooperative, and confrontational.
Now, while all of these traits at first seem
not that great,
this could also mean
that as a self-centered person,
we could entice the Ymir to properly
join our side
if she gets what she wants as it's safe
to assume that a self-centered person
will only care to look out for themselves,
negating the possibility
that Ymir could be entirely on the tight
and side if she is not getting what she wants
out of them.
So if we can find out what she truly wants,
this could be our way to lure her into
joining our side, at least temporarily.
We don't have to be best friends.
We just have to prove
that keeping us alive will benefit her
more than if she decides to kill us
and join the Titans.
Because remember,
we don't know what she knows
nor whose side she's really on, at least yet.
And for starters, this means
I would keep a close watch on Christa
and make sure that she doesn't
leave our sight
because she is the one person who Ymir
is seemingly taking a liking to so far.
Now, with all this being said,
I still wouldn't waste time
just standing around twiddling my thumbs
because trying to convince the Ymir to join
our side is our last resort,
which means these folks shouldn't sit around
and they should start moving
because trying to escape
while Ymir keeps these titans busy
will give us the time
that we need to get away.
If by some miracle, there are a few horses
that have been crushed, Ymir Titan form
kills and slaughters the other titans,
but she eventually gets pinned down
and begins to get eaten alive until
Christa screams at her to destroy the tower.
Instead,
she breaks free from the Titan mob and begins
destroying the tower,
making it fall on the rest of the Titans
before she saves the rest of the scouts,
telling them to grab on to her hair
as the tower comes crashing down.
But nothing can stop these abominations.
And suddenly they burst out of the rubble
and pin Mir's titan form down.
And the Scout rookies can do nothing
but look on in sheer horror.
But suddenly Eren and his crew arrive
to save you, Mir and the rookies.
But in the horrifying process,
Ymir gets badly injured.
The scouts retreat to the top of the wall
to recover.
As Christa tries to convince everybody
that Ymir is a good guy.
But Glasses Girl is skeptical as hell
because if they're wrong,
she might just be the next horrifying
female titan all over again.
And she discusses with Mikasa
what they told Eren
the night before about a horrifying secret
involving one of the soldiers in front of us.
Because nearby, after all this bloodbath,
Reiner finally cracks and confesses
to Eren the most insane secret ever.
The secret that glasses girl and
everybody else already suspected for a while.
And he tells Eren to join him
because Reiner admits to Eren that he is
in fact the armored titan and mentions
that Bertolt is the colossal Titan,
the titans who broke the wall
after 100 years of peace
and the ones who caused evidence mother's
death and mentions that their mission
is the extinction of mankind itself.
Eren tries
to keep his cool, but at the last minute,
his calm face breaks and Reiner spots
this mixer, lunges in for the kill,
but it's no use.
And this causes the two to begin the most
insane Titan transformation in history.
And these two former scouts
reveal their true, horrifying Titan forms
and everybody prepares for battle yet again.
OK, this is some diagonally cut to peanut
butter on toast type crap.
What glasses Girl told Eren the night before
was that these two twin transformers Reiner
and Bertolt came from the same area
as the female Titan and were close with her
growing up, despite the fact that they almost
never spoke to each other during training
or at the Academy
and in trying to take down the female twin
earlier,
Glass's girl thinks that these two dudes
passed on information to the female Titan,
and that's how she found
Eren in the first place.
Now, knowing
all of this circumstantial evidence
makes it a little surprising how they left
Eren alone
long enough for him to mess up
and get discovered by these two guys.
Because if
we have to operate on probabilities,
it was quite probable that Bertolt and Reiner
would have needed Eren to some degree
whether they would have needed him
to join forces with them
or take him out as the only ally
to Titan member of the Scouts
as their only trump card,
Eren was most likely at the target
for Bertolt and Reiner to confront.
And these scouts should have done their dance
to try and keep him apart from those two,
because knowing about their terrifying secret
was their only trump card.
And if they cleverly and purposely kept
Eren away from these two,
whether that would have been by pretending
to reprimand Eren, taking him away,
or forcing him on an expedient mission away
from this location.
The Scouts could have kept up the illusion
that these two Titans
were still leading them on.
They rushed it and got sloppy.
And this is what led Eren
to getting discovered,
which makes sense
because this guy is a terrible liar.
Also, Mickelson
son knows that Reiner is the better fighter,
and even then, she failed to take Reiner out.
Hell, the distance that she was
when Reiner was discovered was unnecessary
because knowing what she knew,
she should have been on Reiner's
ass nearby from the start.
These two titans explode into existence
along with an enraged, tight, in-form Eren,
and the scouts can do nothing
but watch as the colossal
Titan throws humor right into its mouth.
They try to kill it, but it's no use
because this monster unleashes
waves of scalding hot steam
that shields itself from the scouts
and with no way to kill it.
They wait out his defenses as they watch Eren
fight the horrifying armor Titan head on.
Minkus tries to slice
open the nape of its neck
a Titans one weakness,
but her blades break instantly,
getting absolutely pummeled
by the armored titan.
Eren thinks fast utilizing
grappling and submission techniques.
He brings the armored
titan down to the ground,
pinning the armored titan into submission
and breaks off its entire arm.
The armored titan gets up
and then expels some of its armor,
becoming much lighter and faster,
which gives me a clue as to how to defeat it.
Cutting the weak points at the Titans
joints in between the armor.
She quickly gets to work and slices
the armored Titans
weak points and helps Eren weaken
it just enough for him to grapple it
down onto the ground again.
But this time he doesn't let go and begins
squeezing the life right out of it
like there's no tomorrow.
But that's when these scouts witnessed
the most horrifying
trick ever
because the armored tiny shifts outer
nearer to the wall
as he yells out for the colossal Titan
to help end the colossal
Titan comes crashing down onto Eren himself.
And the two monsters kidnap Eren's body
by tearing it from his Titan
the form, and leaves everyone injured and
beaten down, escaping off into the forest.
OK, this has officially become
the biggest crapshoot since the 2022 Oscars,
but this battle from the get go was flawed.
Eren is the most important tactical assets
that the scouts have,
and they should have protected him.
Better glasses.
Girl should have left one group
to keep Bertolt busy
and then order the rest of the entire scout
squad to attack Brian
along with Eren, because Bertolt probably
can't keep up the steam power forever.
And then it would be three to four people
versus one
while the rest of the scouts
and Eren take on Reiner
If I was glasses girl, I would observe that
the Colossal Titans armor does not cover
every square inch of its body.
There are exposed areas
where the plates of armor do not touch.
I would order all of my scouts
to attack these spots
in coordination with Eren's attacks,
which, to be brutally honest, kind of sucked.
Eren,
from what we saw, simply threw haymakers
like he had all the time of the world,
despite the fact that each of his punches
didn't do shit.
And while grappling
was a solid move on his part,
this was risky as hell
because it meant getting close to this dude
while he had a chance to lay one,
if not more strikes on him.
And this guy is clearly a striker
and the better fighter
because, I mean, look at this guy.
He's literally built like a brick shit house.
And since Eren was fighting out in the open
and did not any type of confined space.
This means that the striker, a.k.a.
the Armor Titan, had way more of a chance
at beating him
where he stood by having the scouts assist
and keep the armored Titan busy.
This would allow Eren to do
what he should have done.
Eren is a human Titan hybrid,
just like Reiner and Bertolt,
which means that he would have been familiar
with managing his energy expenditure
as a large animal.
And in terms of energy metabolism, the bigger
the animal, the more energy they expend.
Now, while larger animals
like elephants and presumably these titans
have adapted to having lower metabolic rates,
which essentially means
that even though they use up more energy,
they're also more efficient
at managing their energy.
But even then,
this still means
that Eren could have played this
to his advantage,
choosing to antagonize and evade
possible strikes
that the armor titan threw at him
eventually
making him use up all of his energy.
Because tiny or not
striking a general uses up a lot of energy
because just minutes before we saw,
Reiner asked Eren to join him,
which means that we already knew that
this guy would not leave until he caught us.
And this means that Eren
could have taken his time with this battle
and should have taken advantage
of the armored Titan's conditioning,
because, like in combat sports,
he should have tried to gas out his opponent.
This is the reason why boxers and mixed
martial artists focus
so much on conditioning over strength,
because while being able to throw
any volume of strikes
without succumbing to fatigue is important.
Forcing the armored time to throw punches
all day at us would have meant
that we would have tired him out
and made him deplete any energy
that he would have had,
making it even easier for the Scouts
and Eren to take him down
and have Eren subdue the armored titan
with the grappling techniques.
Hours later, the rest of the squad recovers
from the terrifying events
that just happened.
As Mikasa awakens in Fright and Arm
and tells her that Eren has been kidnaped
and they're waiting for reinforcements
and horses
before they can go after him, causing
everyone to be all droopy and sad as balls.
But this guy tells everybody to cheer up
and says that Eren is a fighter.
And this totally not, to paraphrase the line,
a motivator shit out of these two,
along with the rest of the recovered squad
who now declare Reiner and Bertolt
to be enemies of the state,
which means they won't stop chasing them
until they are captured. Injured.
Glass's girl
then tells the squad that she suspects
that the two titans are already exhausted
and have likely have taken a break nearby
to recharge their Titan abilities,
which means that while they rest, the Scouts
still have a chance to get them.
But she mentions that
they've had a deep into Titan territory,
an area swarming with horrifying flesh eating
titans, and warns everybody
that they might not make it back home
because what lies ahead of these scouts
is truly terrifying.
The group suits up and heads out
to save Eren and captured these two titans.
Meanwhile,
Eren finally wakes up badly damaged,
along with the Ymir in the same boat as him.
He looks up and sees an exhausted
Reiner and Bertolt,
who have taken their ODM gear and tells them
that they're too damaged to turn into Titans
and that they're surrounded by Titans below
them just waiting for the chance to eat them.
Making the possibility
of escaping impossible.
Reiner then says that they have a plan
to take these two back to their hometown
during the night
when most of the Titans
will not be as active.
Eren gets enraged
and threatens to kill them all,
but Reiner tells him to save his breath
because he's going to need it.
OK, right now we are in some deep shit,
Eren, and you, Mayor, aren't safe.
It's just them against Reiner, Bertolt
and the Titans right below them, just waiting
for the chance to tear them apart
and use their bones as toothpicks.
It's unlikely they're ever going to make it
out of this forest alive.
With so many titans
nearby, Eren has Stomper hands
Ymir is injured
and we don't have any horses right now.
As much as it sucks, we only have one thing
on our side potentially, and that's Ymir,
because Reiner and Bertolt are currently
the only ones
with ODM gear, but they're out of energy
and aren't able to turn into titans.
And knowing the importance of Eren
and how much the scouts
value him, it's beyond certain
that the Scouts will be looking for him,
which means we don't need to run.
But simply by time.
I would try and convince Ymir
to join our side for starters, since she at
the moment is more capable than us.
And again, she isn't loyal to any one person
as long as she gets what she wants.
Reiner
as well is clearly the one with temper issues
and seems to be a little mentally fragile.
So I think it wouldn't be impossible
to piss him off to the point that he tries
to come close to show us who's boss.
And once he gets close enough,
this is when we could try and tag team
in with
you mere subduing him
enough to either where we steal his ODM gear
or get his gear off of him and throw it down
towards the Titans.
And even if Bertolt still has his ODM gear,
by the end of this,
he won't be able to save everyone, meaning
we'll have effectively trapped everyone here
buying us more time until the scouts
come to rescue us as everyone loses his shit.
Ymir chimes in and mentions that she thinks
the beast titan from earlier
is the one who's responsible
for the recent Titan infestation.
She and Eren.
Then notice Reiner starting to talk and act
weird to the point that they realize
he's developed almost a split personality.
He's been undercover,
serving as a soldier for so long
he doesn't know whose side he's on anymore,
but Bertolt tells him to cool it
and he suddenly snaps back to normal
like a true psycho.
Regina then tells Ymir to join their side
and that they'll forgive her
for eating their friend years ago
and mentions
that if she joins them, she'll rescue her
close friend Christa to keep her safe,
making this a tough deal to turn down.
So she accepts and suddenly they
then all see in the distance
green smoke,
which means the scouts are closing in.
Bertolt and Reiner are then beat up Eren
and try to escape with the two.
But in the madness,
the amateur sees creased
and the distance within the scouts
and she tells Reiner
that now's their chance to save her.
But Reiner tells her
that they'll come back later for her.
As in their current condition, they're not
strong enough to take on all of the scouts.
But Ymir's got some sweet shit
between Christa and her and forces Bertolt
to crash telling these two scout traitors
that her Titan form
is meant for this environment
and that if she turns on them,
they won't be able to stop her.
She demands that
if they want her to join their side,
they're going to need to rescue Kristen
now or else.
And so the two are forced to agree
as the scouts begin to close in, they notice
something is not right because Bertolt
and Reiner are nowhere to be found.
Only you, me and this skinhead dude asks what
she's doing just hanging around on a tree
but that's when Armin notices that the mayor
is looking round for someone
and he sees her spot.
Christa But before he can do anything,
you mere snatches up Christa and eats her,
and she makes a run for it.
Meeting back up with Bertolt and Reiner
nearby, and Reiner
turns back into the armored titan and helps
all of them escape from the scouts, forcing
Mikasa to stand by and watch in the distance.
OK, we now have a real problem because now
our worst enemy has all of our trump cards.
But the one thing I don't get is why they let
arguably the second most important person
there, aside from Eren near the front lines
I'm talking about Christa or his story,
if you prefer, based on what happened
when we discovered
that Ymir was a Titan,
it was painfully obvious
how close Christa was to Yammer based on how
she was talking to her on the tower.
And Skinhead was the only person
who was present at the tower
and now is riding with the scouts,
meaning he should have her later
this information to the scouts beforehand.
It's unclear
exactly whose side you mirrors on.
However, based on how alert
the city must have been
from the disaster of the female Titan,
they should have never trusted Yammer
to begin with
and used as much caution with her as they did
when they first found out
that Eren was a Titan.
This means that they should have found a way
to use Christa as bait on the off chance
that Ymir turned out to be against them,
because without an increase to is
the only thing they had left to lure Ymir in.
Now, nothing may come from this.
As we saw that
Raina didn't even want to go back for her.
However, bringing her along as a plus one
when we literally had dozens of scouts
already as backup makes no sense.
And in reality,
they should have kept Christa away
from the front lines in the first place.
This tactic would have likely
forced her to stay with us
and would have forced Raina
and Bertolt to abandon Mayor entirely
in order to not get caught.
You'd think after the female Titan fiasco
that these guys
would have learned their lesson by now.
Helpless as Adam gets taken away,
the scouts rushed like hell to get Eren back
because the future of humanity rests
in his hands.
Suddenly, Titans behind them
show up and start charging after them.
They can't turn back.
Meanwhile, on the armored
Titan, the mayor spits Krysta out
and she reacts in shock that her best friend
is siding with the enemy.
But he, Ymir pops out and tells her
that she needs to come with them,
otherwise they'll both be killed
and that they will never be truly safe
from the horrors of the Titans
within their city.
But Christa thinks she's crazy and tells her
that she will always be her friend
and that it's not too late to turn back.
But suddenly the shit show begins.
The scouts catch up and try swiping
Eren from Bertolt a grip.
Mikasa
slices Ymirr's eye as the armored titans
shields Bertolt and Eren within its hands,
and the rest of the scouts
try to get him out,
make a said, then gets up close and personal
with the mayor's horrifying Titan form.
And Christa then tries to make me cause
I feel bad for Ymir situation and tells Ymir
to not fight back.
But Mikasa doesn't give two shits
and is more than willing to kill Ymir
right here
and now if she decides to turn against them.
Meanwhile, the scouts
try to get her out and make Bertolt feel bad
about betraying his own kind, causing him
to go full on crazy and says that someone
needs to spill blood for change to happen.
Making this guy one of the most dangerous
human beings alive right now.
Suddenly, even more tines come from the front
and all of the scouts fall back
because all hell is about to break loose
the armor titan breaks
through all of the hungry
titans
as they try to eat the humans on top of him.
The Scouts are shocked at the madness
and even say, Is this hell?
But Commander
Erwin flies by them on his horse,
leading a horde of hungry
titans to the armored Titan Ymir, and Birch
holds a location.
He intends to use the Titans bloodlust as
a means of distraction in order to free Eren.
Commander
Irwin orders his troops to charge into
what could be the very last
fight of their lives.
And just then a titan comes in and eats
his entire armhole, dragging him away
while he continues to give orders
like a frickin stud.
Dozens of scouts
get their flesh eaten in seconds
as they try to ride
through the Sea of Titans.
The armored titan also finally uses his hands
to get the other Titans
off of him, exposing Bertolt and Eren.
And finally arm
and manages to get under Bertolt skin,
saying that they're doing
horrifying experiments on Annie
as they speak, pissing off the two traitors
to the core.
And Commander Irwin shows up out of nowhere,
half dead and frees Eren before
continuing his bad Assery and Marcus
and the scouts run away, also saving Christa
in the process and making her realize
that Ymir is lying to her about everything
but the armored Tynan anchor starts throwing
titans, killing more scouts in the distance
and stabbing
Mika and Eren dead in their tracks.
And then they come across
the same time that eight Eren's mother
horrifying them both to the bone.
OK, this is some Harlem Globetrotters
slam dunk type bullcrap.
These scouts,
it seems like they don't have a brain
who's the most important person here, Eren.
So why didn't they provide him
with any means to protect himself?
When they first got back,
they were clearly in possession of some odium
of which they could have just given to him,
which would have made him at least somewhat
more self-sufficient. Yet they chose not to.
And now, as predicted, he's
more of a liability than an asset.
And this guy, he failed to save Eren's mother
five years ago to this very same Titan.
There was absolutely no reason
for him to play the hero card.
And instead of simply blocking
that tie in hand
and going for the home run
in taking this time out
all on his own,
he should have taken advantage
of the situation
and should have used that split
second opportunity to save Eren,
opting to swing him up to the nearby trees
rather than trying to fight this time head on
because A had her own gear anyways.
And this guy knew that Eren
was the most important person to the mission.
Meaning this is one of those instances
where fleeing would have been
the better choice than fighting this guy.
I admire his desire
for revenge and redemption,
but come on,
he let his emotions and Hiro complex
get the best of him
and he paid the ultimate price.
Eren, quickly gets freed by Mikasa
just as he watches one of his dear friends
get caught and hopelessly gets picked up.
He tries to turn into a Titan,
but nothing happens,
forcing Eren to watch as his fellow
friend is eaten alive, thanks to him
yet again being a useless piece of turd.
This breaks out in for a sec
until Mikasa snaps him out of it, boosting
Eren's confidence
and he yells out and unleashes a new power,
causing all titans nearby
to attack this Titan
and even Bertolt and Reiner.
This is why these two wanted to capture him,
because Eren has something that can change
everything.
The scouts make a run for it, and Ymir
even switches sides out again and saves
Christa before staying behind to hold off
Bertolt and Reiner.
Later, the scouts find out
thanks to glasses girl
that the Titans found at Skinheads
Village appear to be humans and residents
of the village itself, meaning that
these Titans could be in fact human elsewhere
they have no idea that outside of the wall,
Maria lies the beast Titan
and this guy who has even more
terrifying plans for this city soon to come.
But what do you think about attack on
Titan Season two?
Let us know what you like
and what you didn't like.
Don't forget to subscribe, leave a thumbs up.
And as always, don't forget to check out
our social media and our How to Be playlist.